what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and Marvel's first family the Fantastic
Four are set to hit the MCU in a brand
new reboot in less than two years now
Kevin feige announced the Fantastic Four
reboot four years ago now and since then
we have learned very little about what
Marvel Studios has planned for this new
Fantastic Four film we know a little bit
about the plot which we'll talk about in
this video but what everybody really
wants to know is who are the actors that
are going to be playing the cast of The
Fantastic Four members we'll break down
what we know today as well as these plot
details that we know basically telling
you everything you need to know about
the current state of the Fantastic Four
film and thank you to hellofresh for
sponsoring this video more on them in a
bit trust me I know we have heard so
many rumors about who the potential
fantastic forecast could be from Margot
Robbie to Adam Driver to Seth Rogen as
the thing well right now as it stands it
looks like we probably have our Sue
storm how however although it was
reported that Adam Driver was supposedly
locked into play Mr Fantastic of the
Fantastic Four Reed Richards aka the
smartest man alive it is looking like
that is not the case actually it's
looking like he passed on it some time
ago and we apparently know the reason
why and I gotta say I think Adam Driver
for this I think Adam Driver is a pretty
talented actor I like him as kylo Ren
and I like him in other movies that he's
been in but after hearing why he'd turn
down the role of Mr Fantastic I think I
like him a little bit more rumors about
Adam Driver playing Mr Fantastic have
been going on for quite some time now
and up until recently a lot of insiders
were stating that it was pretty much
locked in that Adam Driver was going to
play Reed Richards he was our Mr
Fantastic of the MCU however recently a
lot of insiders came out and stated that
they heard Adam Driver actually passed
on the role some say that it is still
possible that he is open to Playing Mr
Fantastic if everything is right however
ever some new information tells us that
he is probably done according to Insider
Jeff Snyder on the hot mic podcast he
said that Adam Driver did receive the
script or part of it at least for the
Fantastic Four film to see if he was
interested in playing Mr Fantastic
Marvel Studios did want him for the role
however he turned it down according to
Jeff Snyder he read the script but
turned it down because he couldn't
connect with the character and trust me
I have read the comments I have read the
comments of a lot of people stating that
they just cannot see Adam Driver as
their Mr Fantastic they can't see him
visually as Mr Fantastic he doesn't have
the proper look to play Reed Richards
but also they can't really see his
personality behaving like Reed Richards
would and I was definitely willing to
give him a chance because again I think
he's a talented actor but I'm kind of
with that group as well he is not who I
picture when I picture Reed Richards I
actually still picture John Krasinski I
think he was kind of a perfect casting
there but it's pretty clear at this
point time that that was a one-off thing
John Krasinski is not going to be our
Reed Richards and apparently neither is
Adam Driver and I respect him for this
because this is a massive role this is
going to be one of the biggest
characters of all time most people would
jump at the opportunity to play Mr
Fantastic in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe this is basically like becoming
the next Iron Man so the fact that he
turned this down is very respectful of
him since he couldn't connect with the
character and probably couldn't do the
character Justice since he couldn't
connect plus he doesn't need it he's
kylo Ren he's got plenty of Fame he's
got a lot of movie offers he's not
struggling for work by any means
whatsoever so that's really nice that he
was in the position to actually decline
the role and apparently he declined
pretty early on quite some time ago
however if Marvel Studios wants you to
play a role they probably don't give up
too easily which is probably why we've
heard all these rumors of him playing Mr
Fantastic up until pretty recently so
kudos to him but I do have to say I do
love who is reportedly going to be
playing Sue storm and I do love a lot of
things about the little that we do know
about the plot we'll break it down in
just a bit but first big thank you to
hellofresh for sponsoring this video
many of you may know that I personally
use hellofresh and I love it it makes
cooking fun easy and it's affordable and
that's why it's America's number one
meal kit delivered straight to your door
and you might not know that they
actually have seasonal recipes right now
since it's summer they have their new
fresh and fit summer menu so if you're
trying to get that beach bud but you're
also trying to eat really great tasting
food it's perfect for you right now it's
peak time for summer produce and
hellofresh make sure you get all the
best picks all season long their
ingredients travel from the farm to your
door in less than seven days for Quality
you can taste if you are trying to
impress your friends this summer by
doing some cooking for them hellofresh
makes it super simple they give you all
of the ingredients and tell you exactly
how to make each meal and the best part
is right now if you go to hellofresh.com
cosmic50 you can use code Cosmic 54 50
off plus free shipping that's
hellofresh.com Cosmic 50 and use code
Cosmic 50 for 50 off plus free shipping
so Marvel Studios wanted Adam Driver to
play Reed Richards and he turned it down
and from what we've heard they wanted
Margot Robbie to play Sue storm however
she turned it down as well and based off
of what we know she'd turned it down
because of money she apparently wanted a
lot of money which is perfectly
understandable she is Harley Quinn she
is Barbie and she's been a star and if
not a part of the main cast of many huge
films Margot Robbie is a superstar but
movies only have a certain amount in
their budget so sometimes it doesn't
work out this is apparently what
happened with Margot Robbie however
their other choice Vanessa Kirby has
apparently accepted the role According
to some insiders now take that with a
grain of salt because some insiders also
said that it was pretty much a done deal
with Adam Driver that he was going to be
playing Mr Fantastic and of course he
ended up not now they didn't ever say he
was Mr Fantastic they just said that it
was pretty much complete the same thing
is basically being said for Vanessa
Kirby what's being said is Marvel has
offered her the role and that she has
actually accepted it and her and Jody
Comer were actually my first picks for
Sue storm I think she will do an amazing
job she's getting a lot bigger recently
thanks to the Mission Impossible
franchise and she's a great actress but
go ahead and let us know what you think
about this choice in the comments down
below now as far as what we know about
the plot of the Fantastic Four Kevin
feige has come out and stated that this
is not going to be the typical origin
story of the Fantastic Four that we know
and that we have seen is the origin
going to be the same sure but are we
going to see that on screen doesn't look
like it why Kevin feige says we've seen
it before this is exactly what they did
with Spider-Man homecoming we never saw
Peter Parker get bit by the radioactive
spider we never saw Uncle Ben die and
why according to Kevin feige because we
have seen it many times before and
that's pretty much how he feels about
the Fantastic Four we've seen it on
screen a few times already most people
know how the Fantastic Four get their
powers and for those who watch and may
not know I'm sure they're going to talk
about it just to say hey remember when
we were you know in space and got powers
or simply maybe some news reporters will
talk about it because that's one of the
cool things about the Fantastic Four
everybody knows who they are so no true
origin story we've also heard that they
are going to be parents already when we
meet them in their first film now this
is big if it's true because their son
Franklin Richards goes on to become one
of the most powerful mutants if not the
most powerful mutant we've ever seen in
Marvel history an Omega Level mutant a
mutant who literally controlled Galactus
basically made Galactus his puppet so if
this is true it's a pretty big setup and
the other thing that we know is actually
what is going to connect the Fantastic
Four to everything else that is going on
because right now we have no idea what
the Fantastic Four have been up to we
have no idea who they know Reed Richards
is a scientist and the smartest man
alive it would make sense that he would
know Tony Stark however in the entirety
of the MCU there haven't been any Easter
eggs or hints that Mr Fantastic could
possibly exist somewhere in the MCU
basically the only thing we've really
gotten is Doctor Strange traveling to
another universe meaning the Illuminati
and meeting the Reed Richards of that
universe but still in our main Earth 818
Universe no mention no hints whatsoever
of the Fantastic Four but what's going
to connect them to everything that is
going to be happening in secret Wars is
one of course Reed Richards is the
smartest man alive and a superhero he
should just simply be involved in this
because well you should want him
involved and two he is going to have
knowledge of incursions and the
Multiverse that will help fight against
Kang and perhaps repair the broken
Multiverse that is actually what happens
in The Secret Wars comics Reed Richards
is the one to restore the Multiverse and
I wouldn't be surprised if that is
exactly what happens in see you after
the destruction and damage is all done
Reed Richards finds a way to restore
everything now who knows what that will
be like after Secret Wars and perhaps
Marvel will take this opportunity to
introduce the mutants in a very
particular way maybe one that we haven't
seen before but regardless of what they
do it's going to put the Fantastic Four
and read Richards on the map to be the
next huge main characters of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe so the Fantastic Four
are clearly and obviously going to be
extremely important and the cast of The
Fantastic Four is going to be equally as
important we want the right cast for
this amazing team and they're going to
be the Fantastic Four team in the MCU
for the next 10 years maybe even more
they're not here for just a few years or
a short period of time this is a
commitment they're here for the long run
so we need an amazing cast and it looks
like Marvel Studios is taking that
pretty seriously and hopefully whoever
they get to play Mr Fantastic is going
to be a great fit right now we've heard
Ryan Gosling could possibly be up for
the role we've heard Matt Smith could
possibly be a for the roll right now
it's unclear but if we hear anything
concrete we'll be sure to do an update
video in the meantime let us know what
you think about Vanessa Kirby and let us
know who you would like to play Mr
Fantastic and what do you think of the
plot we'll announce our giveaway winner
this week but we're also starting a new
monthly giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends
items or some DC items all you got to do
is subscribe and leave a comment down
below we pick one winner at the end of
each month and the winner picks one
prize you can also find us on patreon
you can check out our website and
Discord server and you can follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as well as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
foreign